foreign
is with us in Seattle hi Carla what's up
hi
um I what's up it's raining
how can we help you today
um my question is that my dad and his
wife have asked my husband and I for a
large sum of money to pay off their debt
my husband and I are retired and we are
debt free
but now we are on a fixed limited income
we do not have what they are asking in
the bank
it would require us to take a draw out
of our retirement accounts
and we would not we don't want to do
that
and I want to respond to dad with
facts and data and not in motion
because I am very emotional and he is a
great salesman
[Music]
so what's your net worth
oh we have uh uh we are millionaires in
the bank yeah Untouchable one million or
ten
what's your net worth
I don't know exactly my husband knows
the exact numbers well give me a round
guess
uh I don't know it's two okay two to
three all right and how old are you
I'm I am 56 and he is 57. okay all right
and what how much money does they want
55 000 for what
um specific
Ally they say to pay off three credit
cards and a car loan what is the premise
that you should give them fifty five
thousand dollars
because you got some money
um because
um the their statement his statement my
dad's statement was in order to get
ahead and be able to do anything in
their later years they want this debt to
be gone so get a job
well he is 80. 80. she is seven it's
already in his later years
I know too late but we have very long we
have we have a lot of longevity in our
family so he is expecting to live
another 10 to 15 years easy probably
it's just so fascinating and
all right I'm out of time but I have to
answer your questions he's a good
salesman he's a bit manipulative you
have trouble saying no to your daddy we
established that and yet you don't want
to do this I think I heard that between
the lines and I kind of think your
husband doesn't want to do it for sure
and there are reasons that we don't what
are the reasons yeah
the reasons are that
amount of money and she will not pursue
it from her own family
um and so I I feel like they're making
the decision
to be in this situation you're the
easier
I am definitely I am so much easier yeah
I'm sorry you're in this situation it's
so hard
even if you're in your 50s you're still
your daddy
and yeah any and it's really hard to own
the fact that he's a manipulative jerk
well he's I well he is
I haven't I haven't even met him but
what you've told me about him I don't
like him
okay who calls up their daughter and
says I'm entitled to 55 000 of your
money and I'm going to send you on a
travel I'm gonna be a travel agent for
guilt trips if you don't give it to me
who does that not the guy I like Carla
what have these conversations look like
how how has he approached you you said
he's a good salesman but what does that
look like or sound like he's always been
in um in sales jobs his whole entire
life but how it went was he uh oh by the
way when you have a uh some time this
next week can you give me a call I I
want to ask you something I'm like okay
so a few days go by and I call and I say
hey you know I'm calling you back you
said you wanted what do you got going on
and he said well
we we have a situation and he presents
his sales
pitch for
why they are asking for what they're
asking
um and they asked a couple other people
before us and now they're asking us and
it would be great you know all of this
would be paid off they'd pay us this
much back over time and it would be you
know
um he he thought that they could pay
back interest which we just kind of you
know like okay yeah whatever no okay if
the situation where if the situation and
the relationships were completely
different
55 000 out of two million and you're not
going to miss it
and no not at all in a heartbeat pay off
my dad or my mom's stuff and just help
out if he's 80 years old but but but the
situation is not different the situation
is what it is and
um and so
um I just you know I'm just gonna have
to tell you what you already know
and give you the courage to do what you
already know you have to do and you
can't live with yourself and your
husband if you do this
so the answer is no
because you're not doing it for any
really good reason you're only doing it
because you're caving
and you're a coward if you do it
am I am I speaking what's been inside
your brain already
um it's not in my brain it's in my gut
and my heart yeah and now I'm putting it
down in your brain yeah it tears you up
because it's your daddy
I don't care how old you get still your
daddy and that's why this is just so
wrong
to put you in this position it's just
wrong and so I'm sorry you're there it
does break my it breaks my heart for you
but I think you and your husband just
sit down and you say we're going to pan
back from this and this is not a
six-year-old little girl looking for her
daddy looking for her daddy's approval
this is a grown very sophisticated woman
that's very bright in her 50s that is
making a conscious decision to say I'm
not going to be manipulated
can I follow up that uh no with but here
is a bunch of information from uh Ramsey
Solutions go to this website matter of
fact I'll give you Financial Peace
University
I would love for them I would love to
help him and help him go through
Financial Peace University I'll give it
to you as a gift well that's very
gracious and you can give it to them
well thank you and I think you and your
husband you just say look we talked
about it our money's tied up in
Investments right now we think you
should go after her relatives money I
think that's an easier mark and it
doesn't make sense for us right now and
I love you but I'm just so sorry we
can't do it at this time it doesn't it's
not convenient for us
well what about what about what about
now that that that's the beginning and
the end of it you don't have to give an
explanation to the salesman you just
said no
no I'm not buying the car no I'm not
buying the purse no I'm about not buying
the manipulation
no no is a complete sentence
Juan Carla let's get you a copy of own
your pass change your future by Dr John
deloney because it doesn't sound like
this is the first time you've had these
type of conversations with your dad it
sounds like there's a history of kind of
manipulative conversation so just taking
some time for you to process that and
heal from that I know it's going to be
hard and you said you've been kind of
lost in your emotions so I'm sure this
is going to be an emotional conversation
it's very hard I mean you're going to be
you're gonna be you feel like a teenage
girl asking to go out on a date or a
teenage girl that thinks she's going to
get grounded you know it's what that's
that's what it activates inside of you
emotionally I don't care how old I'm 62
and I can feel it right now yeah you
know and I I get that I understand that
so it doesn't go away it doesn't it
doesn't change and so but what you do
the only way to deal with it is to pan
back from the emotions and say okay
we're going to deal with this based on
facts be very gentle and very quick and
short and no is a complete sentence and
it's not a big discussion you do not owe
an encyclopedia worth of reasons
it's our stuff's tied up we don't think
it's a good move and we think you should
get the money from her family and we're
not able to do it right now so right now
we're the answer is now we love you we
hope it works out for you matter of fact
we're going to put you through Financial
Peace University but no yep end of
sentence no more discussion we're not
going to debate this we're not going to
let him drag this down the thing he's
not going to solve the objection because
the objection is over
it's over it's a complete sentence it's
a complete sentence and then you don't
have to feel guilt and shame absolutely
not
and the Very fact that that that's all
here is the reason for the no
exactly it's not her it's not she should
get it from them it's not that um you
have it tied up in Investments it's the
very way that the whole thing is handled
and the whole thing is couched in and
you don't want to do it
and by the way it's your money you do
not have an ethical or a moral
obligation to give manipulators money
just because they happen to begin to you
it's just not there what about the Bible
says to honor your parents it does not
say to honor their misbehavior if your
dad calls up and he's doing cocaine he
needs some money you don't give him
money that's not what the Bible's
talking about it says we honor the
position of fatherhood not the
misbehavior of the sole individual that
is in the position
we honor the position of President not
the misbehavior of the president
it's a different thing I honor the
position of motherhood but if mom's an
alcoholic we don't honor that
okay that's the thing you're looking at
and so you're not biblically or morally
or spiritually or psychologically
obligated in any in any sane person's
book
okay so you're set free right now
right now